مقالات جائره بشكل لا يصدق الصحافه دمرت
علاقاتي هذا ما قاله الامير هاري على منصه
الشهود في افادته للمحكمه العليا في لندن
في قضيه انتهاك الصحافه بصوره غير قانونيه
لخصوصيته منذ طفولته حتى شبابه المتهم هو
مجموعه ام جي ان الملكه لصحيفه ذا ميرور
البريطانيه اما الادعاءات الرئيسيه فتتضمن
33 قصه خبريه من اصل 147 منشوره في ديلي
ميل وساندي ميرور وثيبل بين عام
1996 وعام 2010 وجميعها اخبار تم جمعها
بطريقه غير قانونيه منها ما يتعلق بشؤون
عائله هاري وعلاقاته وحفلاته في سن
المراهقه هاري قال ان الصحافه حاولت تدمير
علاقاته وتقليص دائره اصدقائه اضافه الى
نوبات من الاكتئاب والبرانويا
في المقابل المجموعه المالكه للصحيفه
اعترفت بان القرصنه حدثت ذات مره نافيه
التنصت على الامير هاري في اي وقت اخر
محامي المجموعه قدم اعتذارا شخصيا لهاري
في المحكمه وقال ما كان يجب ان يحدث هذا
ولن يحدث مره اخرى مؤكدا انه في حال تبين
وجود ارتكاب مخالفات اخرى فسيتلقى الامير
اعتذارا اكثر شمولا